[Musik]
medien gerne bis privatsphäre und
privates privat will privat ist das
heißt alles was privat ist öffentlich
und auch dem moment wird medien das
öffentlich mache ich ja selber nimmt
privaten ich selber öffentlich wenn er
ein fahrrad würde profil mehr denn nötig
eben wir es wissen und mit der schlacht
setzende unterhosen und vierziger und
laufen als vorzüge aber das wollte ich
nicht zeigen aber dass wer privat
[Musik]
ich glaube einmal wie früher als kind
also behandelt hätte im höfchen
behandler hätte ich ritalin braunsberg
unter sorge also mit mir ruhig stellen
glaubt mit deren energie aber die
energie suppe
man glaubt es macht man mal was ganz
ganz schlecht auf
wenn ich nicht weiß warum die töne durch
gott dann wirklich ganz langer der tür
klopfen und hoffnung stirbt zuletzt dass
ich den satz da gibt es mir wirklich ich
glaube ganz fest daran dass einfach
alles möglich ich irgendwie das sind
natürlich mit einer großen frau wie sage
was ich stehen wie schwerter mit dem
motto was das eigene haus
[Musik]
bis ende des festes
ja
künstlerinnen und künstler aus aller
welt dass ich eine ganz wichtig aber das
durchmachen frau im programm
also natürlich notruf ist also wie
gesagt ich begrüße sie mir zwei jahre
das land ich bin in zürich groß wurde
und gelohnt sagt er musste die bonner
ihr wer bist du er war die standuhr wir
sind noch relativ langer zusammenarbeit
mental brutalstmöglich das ist gar nicht
so schwer
[Musik]
das neue programm von ursus und
nadeschkin tanz der zuckerfee laumen
fähre
heute wird das programm zum ersten mal
vor publikum gezeigt eine test
vorstellung die erste von insgesamt 18
also hört erwartet uns wieder auf die
test vor ganz viel material ohne eine
reihe folgten warum ihr stil hat das
macht sinn
romy spur von roth der vater herrn und
rita zimmer und duscharmaturen an der
baustelle erkennt schon einbauen
ich berate stunden dass ich nicht nervös
wenn sich so eine aufgabe zwei tage wo
gar nicht gut aber es hätte aber bis
beruhigend wenn es sie denn das klappt
sowieso nicht und die dritte gespannt
zum morgen war es klappt oder es klappt
tom riesa ist nicht nur regisseur als
co-autor entwickelte gemeinsam mit nadja
und rostig stücke botschafter figuren
hat mir die glaubt jetzt verstehe ich
sehr dafür dass sie als das drobs mit
seinem lied verschrobene humor mit ihrem
nicht anarchismus das hätte man gern und
die figur sehr guter türöffner und
verstößt das mit uns mit wir verstehen
seine ganze kunst avantgarde oder
erobere
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich einfach schneiden
[Musik]
wie bringt zwickl trust das sehen wir
wollen wir machen eine probe und genau
das wird schnell gut no
was suchst du bist schnell aus der haut
und haar ihre blüten spielt alles wieder
weniger schnell
natürlich lässt mich alle schon april
kanadischer kühlt es sich auf völlig
flexibel an alle schon wieder aufhören
[Musik]
und ganz wichtig doch nicht ganz frisch
erklärt auch zu befriedigen egal was ist
schließen frieden egal was nicht jedem
[Musik]
im entzug muss aber nicht stimmt und
voran heißt es so schön ich dann richtig
liefere ich komme da alles lernen
gestern zum teil geschrieben jetzt nun
wie man nur die richtige reagieren doch
das was mir wichtig zum beispiel also
lachend richtig es wird in die masse vor
super und da besser unterstützen an das
ich dann an dich selbst bruder der
joseph
ross & nadeschkin fliegen nach edinburgh
es ist eine reise zurück zu ihren
anfängen schon in jungen jahren sind sie
im englischsprachigen raum vor kleinem
publikum aufgetreten jetzt viele jahre
später wagen sie dieses abenteuer erneut
[Musik]
noch einen abstürzen kann nicht
funktionieren als interessant oder
lustig finde aber schön ist natürlich
das mache was mir wann hätten extreme
freyung wird kein mensch erwartet in der
business oder extrem befreiend und das
so haben reichlich immer wieder und in
der schweiz kriegt man das natürlich
nicht so schön sein
das stimmt nicht sagt jeder sich nicht
stark genug tragen und flug noch das war
alles sehr schön grün und ich das k4 wir
brauchen extra minuten hatte musste
wusste nicht genau was aber braucht sehr
viel wasser statt immer nur in sein
empfiehlt laut beruf den bussen das
edinburgh fringe festival in schottland
ist das größte kulturfestival weltweit
täglich gibt es über 2000 aufführungen
an 317 spielstätten die konkurrenz ist
groß
vier wochen lang haben muss und
nadeschkin täglich einen auftritt auf
ihrer kleinen bühne
es sind oft behauptet dass die erste
woche schwierig wird und dass wir weiter
kracher oder deprimiert sind und wenig
blöd aber wenn denn nie passiert dass
ich glaube wir müssen die ängste das
museum ab bis sich hat mir die vier
wochen nicht wirklich teurer
die hofheimer kämmerlein fehlt aber die
sammlung ein älteres publikum wurden mir
crouch hat sich
weil sich ganz schlimm sein wird der den
dass ich jetzt wahrscheinlich eintreten
sechs kosmonauten collection
lodestone synchronschwimmen die
druckversion was gespürt es jetzt wenn
sie das land nicht dass da überall
plakate und für einige hat er diese zeit
dass mir aber dass ich los
[Musik]
ganz am schluss bin ich noch mal
ja das ist jetzt einfach kostüm mit und
zuspruch nicht fehlen oder sag jetzt mal
das ist jetzt aber nicht wahr
es ist nass der hand noch kein problem
oder sachen wo im werk sind wir müssen
das bringt uns weiter und irgendwann
wird man sarkozy jeder konfession unsere
chance gut und es wird einmal die
schweiz gut und man muss zwischen oder
muss das wetter rebic er da wird es
schwierig werden einen kranz spüren
ich glaube dass ging das jetzt für
einige von euch unten durch zu rennen
unter dem unter dem haus durch zureden
von riesa arbeitet als regisseur für
verschiedenste produktionen in ganz
europa hier zum beispiel in bremen für
die oper das horoskop des königs würde
man verlege liegt das heißt wenn ich bin
ich ganz bei ihnen
und wenn du nach krimi nie ganz weg
natürlich brennt bin so froh aber in der
tat in seitige phase bin ich wie
gebieten grundsätzlich das vorhaben so
viel wie wenig das lässt sich ja gern
analytisch herrscht einfach mit der
riesige gruppe schafft für großes bild
und man kriegt wie andere resultat aus
der größte unterschied ist dass ich in
so ein apparat wir staatstheater meiner
opera house in moskau landschaft geht es
sind einfach viel licht und bisher alle
wieder organisiert deshalb ist mit der
technik das ist glaube ich die
unterschied dem umkehrschluss börsen
bringt mir niemals assistentin aber mir
war das liest ich glaube stand in wales
auf schreibtischen bühnenbild aus dem
stand in war and und alles bringt and
holt nach zwei wochen in edinburgh
hoffen horses und nadeschkin noch immer
darauf endlich einmal vor vollem haus zu
spielen
damals schon mal testet dann richtig
[Musik]
fri
hättest du der ballon muss auch den sack
der flyer die ganze zimmer ist nun ein
kleines rätsel muss wir sind nicht alles
machen noch leben wir nur erreichen wenn
ihr job ist dass man jetzt hier können
und bin 0 betrafen und druck werfen
ihren andere zieht aber ich bin sicher
so viele ebenen einer sitzbank
lesepublikum andere sichtweisen die
kenne sich abstrampeln nach publikum
da sind ganz viele sachen sind so
flashbacks
[Musik]
er hat ständig michaele zirkus machen
und da gibt es hier zwei wochen als
ferienlager in wiesbaden der kurs kurz
und geht herum hängt es sehr stark sehr
hat sich nicht das ist normal wenn sie
mit dem mikroskop sehen schlecht
organisierten hätte es wirklich nicht
klebt uns hat ganz komische kunst denn
ich habe da wirklich film riesigen
homann treffen die teile man immer
wieder gern
danach folgt lautet denn da geht es um
die uhr geschaut zdf fernsehgarten die
hand zirkus thema kann
und dann verhaut zirkus könnte die
background für neues machen und dann
seid ihr dran natürlich jahr will der
mieter hat alles gemacht und sind in
zirkus machen hängt ab und merkt scheiße
als blöd und audi hat das ist ein neuer
blick sehen denn wir hätten 2
[Gelächter]
das sehen wir jeder samstag also ich bin
1 gmx und technologie haben wir sind
eher des anstiegs zürichsee pro monat
anhand straße ruft rick machen und den
autonomen mit zur musik und schon
klappte und den heimweg machen wir das
jetzt aufhöre wenn du merkst hat dass
mir franz eine dritte oder villa sein 29
jahre abzugeben
[Musik]
und das obwohl viele es werden
klassische rollenverteilung frau am name
und programm sport möchte sich ja die
schlimmste vorstellung statt auf der
bühne und bitte vor die bank of china
backstage
[Gelächter]
gegen ende spüren die beiden mehr und
mehr dass sich das wagnis gelohnt hat
die zuschauer sind und doch neugierig
geworden
der schönste lohn für die beiden
[Musik]
hallo ich extrem cool war mir schon mal
ein richtig dass man plane ausprobiert
auf verschiedenen bühnen und dass ich
größer bin und das 250 53 das ist ja
nicht so groß aber jetzt zu sagen ist
das groß das hat sich ein anderer
rhythmus ausprobieren und vor allem
irland litauen unternehmen immer noch
über flyer ja ja ja
die bergrettung jedoch lässt sich jeder
doch jetzt und den hund den safes weiter
der vater die ried wo man gerade trifft
vor allem den mangel später sachen
energie gigant
das ist eigentlich erstaunlich gut
gaddafi los und ab es ist sehr es um
bereiche das festival das hat sich bis
zum schluss nicht ganz
mehrheit dem er das sehr unterschiedlich
sind
nach zwei stunden der erste konflikt als
keine klärt hand und war schon gut wenn
das opfer ist ein konflikt heißt nicht
dass man sich nicht verstaubt und man
versteht einfach die andere ansichten
als aber der unterschied ist dass man
weiß man wirklich nicht schaden
und dass man letztlich am gleichen
strick ziehen
wir wissen beide dass das anliegen ist
eine tasse mehr versuchen mittels machen
aber wenn ich also training ist jedes
jahr im ruhm
[Musik]
minute sogar das stück gemacht muss er
das wichtigste zum thema trainings solo
wären wir natürlich auch immer schon
gewusst hat mir sind sehr sehr
unterschiedlich der hand ganz klar ein
universal- und eigene werke was auch
über schnitten aber nur und zum anderen
das solo genau auf dem u-boot die idee
vom so logisch ob sie das die han solo
programm auf der bühne und nagelte
soloprogramm blödes flachland aber macht
die auf der bühne ist natürlich zwei
komplett verschiedene programmmacher
sehen davon haben prallt darüber hätten
von denen klar war in dem ich dahinter
hoch professionell präsentieren und
ihnen geschnellt dafür vorstellen dass
singen die nudelauflauf natürlich nur
schwer sagen
die komische den bau die amerikanische
marke worden die schauspieler sich chris
christie orte
[Musik]
klavier braucht keine gemüse also ich
habe einfach gesagt mandalas krise
kommen wird kein blut ohne gut sind sie
mehr haben der lange pause gemacht ohne
rücksicht darauf dass mir ein bisschen
abtrainieren
das heißt mein adrenalinspiegel springer
blieben und hat ständig oder einem
produziert nicht nur drinnen abbauen
ich habe relativ dunkel wie burnout
bernard-marie die ecke gestellt und
natürlich nicht gäbe kaputt gegangen
der papa von ihm sondern jeder nach wo
nicht meint ihr habt jetzt wieder ganz
vertraut mir gesagt hat du musst nur
dass der adrenalin wert aber hunt und
das schon besten mitspieler also
therapie steigen nach vorstellen
ich war ganz früher klären das ist
schönes bild offen jeder baum gezogen
werden
man muss nicht sein bier und das hat
mich überrascht röhre und und einer
schlaufe machen nach auch die säuberung
verziehen und dusche warten bis apple
kunden hilft und dann kontern
[Musik]
noch bevor ursus und nadeschkin nach er
den blau weißen haben sie eine
zweijährige auszeit genommen
woods war mit seiner familie auf einer
weltreise und hat einen eigenen
projekten gearbeitet unter anderem an
einem neuen buch
nadja hat in ihrer auszeit unter anderem
in berlin ein stück über obdachlosigkeit
entwickelt geschrieben und inszeniert
ihre dazu begründete zum buhmann im napa
neu orientiert das auch machen aber
nicht mitmachen user finden was ich
privat wieder madita versorgt sich immer
verpasst der hand bleibt sie beruflich
machen möchte ich nie können sondern
inszenierte gottes so ein stück und was
ich für mich total ich angst dass sie am
grips theater trifft nadja ihre beiden
schauspieler und ich würde gern
irgendwie zwei tage mehr rausnehmen im
herbst für eine video hoffen dass wir
mal wieder zeit haben auch vielleicht
das eine oder andere rausschmeißen oder
so oder ich eure erfahrungen
ich dachte immer und stück wald ist der
mensch selber schuld und selber
verantwortlich für was er tun und alles
wird das stück gebaut haben musste ich
diesen diese haltung komplett umbauen
weil es gibt ganz viele die einfachen in
einer verkettung von negativerlebnissen
einfach die haut um und aus dem leben
und funktionieren nicht mehr
seit zwei jahren läuft das stück aus die
maus erfolgreich am berliner grips
theater
die show ist fast jedes mal ausverkauft
billiger das leben gekostet und ich bin
so wird die weite welt habt ihr gemacht
weil ich ein stück scheiße
[Musik]
die texte sind nicht am schreibtisch
entstanden die sind reine im plus auf
grund von der info wo mir überholen
durch ihre recherchen obdachlosen
[Musik]
es gibt immer das gespräch nach dem
stückchen kinder ganz viel frau hand
wenn sie waren sie nicht ein stück hand
vor der situation dass ein das könnte
passieren
also man muss aufpassen dass krieg nicht
raum stand dass ihnen das passiert und
trotzdem muss man ihnen sagen dass
zumindest sorge tragen dass ich dasselbe
passiert und wir haben auch mit
obdachlosen getestet ja die fanden das
ja mit obdachlosen und liefern das aber
wir haben viel zu harmlos das was uns
passiert auf der straße was uns gesagt
wird mitten ins gesicht dass es viel
viel schlimmer
genau deswegen lassen wir das mit dem
stück scheiße drin auch wenn manchmal
die lehrer finden das ist ein bisschen
hat aber das ist was die halt erleben es
gibt manchmal autofahrer die halten
ankurbeln wenn es darunter und
beschimpfen die einfach so aus dem
nichts raus und das ist ein hartes leben
also wir dürfen das nicht verharmlosen
auf der bühne sonst denkt ihr das ist ja
ganz lustig und wollte das dann auch und
das ist nicht lustig da zu lieben
[Musik]
ich bin mit mir im burgund der laxey und
haben das nicht wenn der wahlkreis
machen und ich bin allein nach lina auch
jähriger das jährige
das war nicht immer nur wer zur mutter
also wenn ich in wellen bis 92 woran das
funktioniert und dann hat im hochland
und hat berlin gerne büro es ist schön
sie zum see und das ist gut in schuss
als team das sich um familie und ich
habe ihm viel über 1000 geräte und über
die obdachlose also er hat die frage
gestellt warum was machen die auf der
straße was ich gar nie rechnen
warum kann man jetzt den namen des promi
handtuch
muss man ein bisschen differenzieren
zwischen obdachlosigkeit und armut in
generell für die meisten jungs straße
leben die wählen dass ich selber ist
eigentlich frei gewählt frei gewählte
armut familie
das hat sich alles im bus herlaufen und
wo die drei bücher kunst aufräumen von
urs wehrli welches seit 2002 erschienen
sind sind links internationale
bestseller
sie wurden in 15 ländern aufgelegt und
allein im deutschsprachigen raum über
eine million mal verkauft es gab
ausstellungen und auftritte in ganz
europa eine eigene serie bei der sendung
mit der maus und sogar eine
sonderbriefmarke bei der post
das ist versöhnlich von der allgemein
schreiberinnen und mein schrieben also
eigentlich trockene veranstaltung die
hand ihre generalversammlung und 1 1
referenten oder wagt sich quasi direkt
die idee ist einfach bestechend
entwickelt hat er sie unter anderem bei
seinen zahlreichen besuchen in
kunsthäusern und galerie hinter dem
applaus steht arbeit wo sus verifiziert
kopien der meisterwerke und ordnet sie
fein säuberlich für seine kunst geht urs
wehrli über der gäste kurz er räumt
alles auf was ihm in die quere kommt
sind vorbei überhaupt nicht objektiv
sein dass die autofahrer bat das relief
zu
90 minuten dauert der bunte spaß bis
alle 100 fahrzeuge in halle und glied
stehen geschafft
ursus wehrli und ich halte jetzt ein
vortrag zum thema kunst aufräumen sind
schon fragen zu dem referat pflicht
sache im alltag wo man eine solistin ist
auch nicht ganz schlecht und eigentlich
pro tisch und irgendwie habe ich aber
sonne luft man die sache zur tiere oder
ordner wo gar nicht so wichtig sind aber
nicht so viel sinn machen
nadia fährt im kältebus mit ein angebot
der stadtmission berlin
im winter fahren ehrenamtliche
mitarbeiter durch die straßen und suchen
obdachlose auf diese bekommen hilfe in
form von warmen getränken oder
schlafsäcken
oft werden sie auch zu notunterkünften
gefahren wie viele notschlafstellen gibt
es dann in berlin im winter ist das also
plätze sind aktuell 1200 1200 und gegen
8000 sind auf der straße wird ist ja wer
in die statistik reinfeld und wenn ich
irgendwie alle diese richtig also da
gibt es mal ganz grobe schätzung
er wusste ja super dann kommen wir dahin
dauert allerdings noch ein bisschen eine
halbe stunde ungefähr
gerne
wo kommst du her
eigentlich aus deutscher da ich kein
weibliches hat mich meine müsse dann mit
nach indien
ich hoffe die haben auch noch ein platz
abstand
wir hatten angerufen und warten sie noch
ein plätzchen frei dies alles gute
das geschäft wird also mit bissigen am
und dann in der notschlafstelle
interviews gemacht
je nachdem mit der novelle geht es
wieder weiter
er hat hausverbot hier
ok
das hat jetzt ein musikalischer beitrag
aber ich brauche
nein du machst es kaputt
problem nur ex technologie sich nach der
polizei verhaftet
ich konnte noch mal wenn er sage sei
krieg wollte papier aber wir haben bis
zum stiftung bringe sie wischt sie sind
sogar lage sei trotz zum schneemann ist
riesig
[Musik]
wir sehen doch liegt die zahl der hand
die zwölf die tesco ständig mehr das
stück das hat jetzt haben jetzt nur eins
zwei drei vier fünf sechs mal bei der
premiere hand versorgt die drei wochen
bei mir habe ziemlich cool
was definitiv im punkt ich warum ich das
theater am wall in der bucht vor der
familien und viel fernseh klagt das kind
und der tat ihnen wie die sandige käfig
staus sind allmählich oder und der täter
immer zeigt was sie vorne machen und wie
wahnsinnig warm dass es in den abgrund
die familie erhebt oder immer mit vier
wird was der andere macht und dreht eine
sehnsucht gottes nicht im bett landet
bei den großen erfolg sondern minister
kann peter streit also die katze vom
jugendlichen
[Musik]
ich würde immer mehr freunde sind
eigentlich weiß ich gar nicht mehr
freunde sind aber familien auf jeden
fall ganz klar ich sehe dass also in der
familie strukturelle studie bestritten
also in der familie schon nicht
unbedingt grund hat sich ein volk das du
verwandt ist oder zahnbürste getan und
es tritt also ein an dass sich ein
größerer im tank abbruch das ist dann
ziemlich gut würde sagen japan spricht
dafür
der fortschrittliche dafür wenn du
normal über gemacht werde so das match
aber am schluss oder sehr stark sind ist
nun bist du immer falsch fragen was hat
einfach so dass du in der falsch
bestimmt ballett unter hip hop warum die
bescheidene so stadt also als partei das
ding das fun tastic trotzig newsroom
nehmen und wenn würden wir das machen
wir sind da die ganze zeit wenig
dahinter zieht dann mache ich da und
sechs für mich aber gerne christ der das
anliegen ist das richtig zu machen um
durch mischen auch studieren
entschuldigung darf ich das mache die
beiden das sind die beispiel richtig gut
überlegen was daran gemacht worum es
geht der gute grund dafür mit infos und
at&t fuße des alpha 680 gar nicht
irgendwie ist es auch eigentlich merkt
das schon wenn ich acht stunden mit den
erprobten tag zweimal pro woche
der mähdrescher so wo es ist sehr
befriedigend hat sich wunderschön hier
haben ich glaube wenn wir das nicht gern
macht denn das wahnsinn jahre strecken
ich habe mir macht das anliegen und ich
lieb' ich liebe die wiederhole ich kann
auch 100 stunden eine kleine ecke viele
ich mir das verstimmt können wir
stundenlang außer blödsinn grube
meine dass ich jetzt aber nicht üppig
geschaffen
also wenn ich finde das ist ja das ist
was in unserer arbeit wichtige sturm
schaffte sie perfekt sie mit großer
sache der sehr akribisch oder mit
rhythmen und sowie der brander sie zum
beispiel auch eine loslösung der prinz
große chaos auf das mal passieren und
erniedrigend noch legal was passiert
etwas passiert
weil ich jetzt nur die anderen nicht die
anderen die andere stimmt dass ich die
ganze hektik was ich mir das chaos
perfekt
normal haben die anarchie über
nebenstraßen ist beschrieb weil sich
irgend erwägt jetzt so und so wie sie
das sagen mir sage nicht das macht den
abgasen und über viele länder brachten
welt funktioniert also hat es an den
energie wo schwarz beschriebene ständig
sie auf klappte unermüdlich die mensch
und ich kenne triebe vorweist
nichtwähler andere götter und der
gleichzeitig auch die betriebe tragen
macht jedoch keine energie ja mensch mit
übersteigertem interesse an zum teil
unnützer sache super tradition auf die
russische mensch wo extrem gaben in
falschen ecke lockt und über die sache
dort stattfinden extrem gut lachen als
extrem herzlicher mensch extrem lustig
mensch und hat seine spezielle humor ist
sehr spezielle mensch weiß nicht ob ich
ihnen jetzt ob es auch wirklich verstand
in kompletter fasziniert mich immer noch
nach 30 oder schon
ich habe ich 20 bin schmerzen mini lang
sind beweglich und für mich bewege sich
wie man nicht wegspült ich hätte weniger
pro woche lang probleme selber so
beweglich kommen dass bastian reinhardt
bis 20 jahre dritter slackline kunden
und wann ich muss sagen ich trainiere
mit der slackline handel und fiel wenig
problem das laut klein zu spüren
geplante operationen können auch sagen
[Musik]
wie kommt man mit dem älterwerden nehmen
mit dem die ganze sitzung gar nicht
glauben immer in einer normalen job muss
derart oft vor dem spiel setzen und
sinnvolle weg sind und das macht er
nicht dass man angst davor ziemlich
verloren
[Musik]
vor der vorstellung
humor ist das wichtigste für mich ist es
ganz ganz zentral das ist ja das was
jetzt kommt was ich jetzt aus das ist
der zünder dachte dass ich es herrscht
dass ich ein richtiger der dance
brauchtum zweite wahl krieg doch petrus
sich absolut sicher dass er sofort nach
das zeigt jetzt hätte das braucht mut
das ist höre ich es natürlich wieso
machst du
ich muss lernen der duden aber wo es mir
gut geht dann sind wir wirklich gut tut
dann bliebe da und das spiel hat mir
vertraut lieber und vagni 40 wird eine
schlacht das auch oder der krise wo
mentaltrainer nicht die große macht dann
würde ich traurig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir waren immer da zu unsicher und ich
sind verrückt dass mir als schauspieler
management der emotionen wo ich trete in
düsseldorf statt aber sie sind ja noch
auf sie wartet der garderobe wo mangels
optimieren da muss man sehr geschickt
s
und matte stehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das zeigt dass er häufig wenn zwei lied
auf der bühne sind
frau x 1 prozent alle danke die hälfte
zieht nummer darüber nach was hantierten
durch noch absolut
[Musik]
die mama ist es heutzutage so dass du
dich wohl aber dass es bei frau bauer
hat ihnen das porsche will sich über
frauen was würde der zwischenfall mit
dem auf heime machen meist gestellten
fragen nicht so nützen so schön ich habe
ich geschaut dass man das leck sinkt die
zeit das nochmal doch mal zeigen einzig
und damit das mal ganz zeigt dass ich
das mit der heilig war immer so quasi
gefunden das ich entscheide ich mache
also mache der 100 prozent und tv rein
passt zu der figur der street view ist
das wichtig für mich dass das denkt man
dich doch er hat sich auch kollidiert
mit dem privatleben extrem also ich hab
die vorteile bietet sie und nicht die
ursache
ich habe
minimaler ist ganz schön ich frage sie
war fürs und ich aus irgendeinem eine
haaranalyse dann nach heubach und wollen
sie abgeschnitten
plötzlich die bleiche blonden kasseler
die dunkle haare und jürgen spiegel
möchte ich sehe einfach mutter und
vertreibt
[Musik]
sie hat mich dass es so schön weist ein
defizit sogar schon
sehen dreifarbig bauer die hatte sich
das total gern sich alleinige blieb
brigitta schroepfer die frau von us ist
choreografen zeitgenössische tänzerin
und dozentin an der zürcher hochschule
der künste
das muss man hat ja eine sehr intensive
arbeitsbeziehung hat ist für sie
selbstverständlich
also die frau gegen niedrig oder i
fertig überhaupt nie aber ich habe auch
von mir oder so also das sind einfach
zwei ganz verschiedene welten
ja und sie schon immer klar dass das
eine arbeitsbeziehung ist mit einem
gesetz das das ist keine rolle gespielt
und ich glaube wirklich also durch ihr
lang bezirk wo sie zusammenhält
arbeitsbeziehung waren andere nehmen
aber ausdrucksvoll wiener bezirk und
ganz viel weil bestimmt also wie die
wahrscheinlichkeit das können wir nicht
einmal mehr zwei und das glück dass ich
weiß dass du verstehst mich nicht
richtig angefangen moment machen
miteinander vor dem weiß ich nicht
du bist ein gerät als wort stufen oder
was was soll ich sagen oder machen oder
also ich zeig dir einfach ein kurzes
teile wurden hier am start mit dem
musikstück und wo es mich wundern etwas
erzählt oder was es für assoziationen
[Musik]
wirklich sehr sehr anregend und die
ausgesät 1 bis 3 jetzt kommt ja ganz ein
anderem musik also ich heute dankt für
mich weil es ganz schwierig mit dem
prinzip nein 25 jobs
ich glaube das ist natürlich als
extremes plus wenn beide meiner frau von
der künstlerischen beruf schaffen
da geht's einfach ganz viel auch warum
sich neben sehr klar wer selber selber
kennt
[Musik]
manchmal ist es so eine sache
und das muss ich mir einfach das paar
gefunden
sie ist ganz wichtig dass man immer
wieder so insel schaffen wo man einer
wirklich für den zum musik suchen ein
kilo
naja ich natürlich hoffe ich ja leute ja
2 stand auf der bühne nehmen die vorher
noch ein lied noch was machen denn fritz
und special guest blick
die idee ich wiederum medizin kunst
außer natürlich nicht sehr groß
[Musik]
doch was durch
überrascht ob
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er hat schon früher märkte den ins
gerade das einfach spaß macht so mit
anderen künstlerinnen und künstler
zusammen auf der bühne zelebrieren das
ist lecker was man kombiniere das hat
das am meisten interessiert das ist
nicht passiert
ich habe mich hat er gleich mitnehmen
ich lachte lunik sie im stress ich liebe
einen abholen
tempo und altem auf dem bellevarde
genutzt und die premium und wünschen
einen schönen tag und der nation und bin
recht heftig gestürzt
widerruft stand von politik und stuft
die hand planen carlos auf das knie
komplett auf verstehen ja amri bildet
sich nicht erst langsam honig merzig
achte gut dass man untersuche das man
sich denken und genau das tue ich mir
das fühlt sich ganz komisch auch immer
ganz locker
das muster zeigen
da werde ich jetzt machen wir das
[Musik]
hier wird man ihr arm aus dass
irgendwelche können bewirken oder
anderen mit dem was wir machen
ich finde jetzt rein global wahl
politisch gesellschaftlich gesehen ist
es total unwichtig was mir machen aber
das war eigentlich vor allem sagen ich
werde das machen wo mehr wichtig ist wo
er ab es geht um mich inspiriert von mir
freude macht im idealfall ist das denn
inspiration aller völker brandes
[Musik]
stolz sind
ich habe mich gesträubt irgendwo bis vor
anderen lied gott machen das ist stoff
media wenn überhaupt nur verliehen
abrollen akw resultate will ich das
einfach mehr ist für roth wurde und was
leben ist totale horror wenn ich muss
rico hast du machst die landestitel es
ist ja nicht besonders viel wert bin ich
wir wollen ihnen untergrund beruf das
schiff und eingeholt 1000 der macht das
ein spaß aber wenn ich das privat muss
machen ja glaube das hängt vielleicht
damit zu finden
ich wollte auch gar nicht so wichtig sie
das match von 100 leuten zu hause
es geht sogar lüthi erfolg ist was sind
ihre silbrigen viel geld von dem die
schädigung privatleute vor dem verbot
und übrigens ihr unterhuber tapete
sondern lernen müssen wird wenn sie sich
als ein wunderbares kann jetzt können
wir doch gar nicht wieder im beethoven
fragenkatalog und wie heißt der
komponist vor der fünften sinfonie von
ludwig van beethoven
beethoven ludwig war - bei
antikommunismus mundart von beethoven
tragen das problem also beethoven mozart
zum beispiel sei der beethoven der
strauß genau den haben wir also peter um
technische einer zu streichen
der pinsel wenn ein maler der seine
kindheit viel dunkler genau da hätte so
viel druck und er hätte es krise sehr
bbk da ist so ein schöner
vertriebsleiter oder sanitätern bild pd
der shop in shop
[Musik]
der staatsrat ali kur dort extrem doch
die schon extrem sich
doch die jungs haben nun die substanz
nur dann zu prüfen
wolle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mehrheit ist komplett verändert werden
derart vielfältig radfahrer logisch wir
sind zwar schräg sie aber wir sind ja
oft die anlasser wahnsinnig sexy und
anstellen oder unerfahren und sachlich
mainburg
ich achte wahnsinnig freuen sie sich
sehr ehrlich klar also dass ich ganz
ehrlich große veränderung in buer nadia
musste ihre hand inzwischen einer
operation unterziehen
sie muss sie nun während mehrerer wochen
schonen ich hatte mich streichelten zwei
jahren merkt dass es nicht stimmt mit
mama warum kann ich ja das hat ein recht
interessiert das hatten doppelten stress
da oder sei es war ein scheiß baute der
schule dass dann der sprecher klar
ihre mutter ist logisch dass der mist
baut und mutter schon chronisch das
hatten beschäftige das nicht lästig für
ihn glaubt spannenden polizist wird die
aktie hand waschen
ich finde das ist schon lustig ist aber
nicht verschmerzt am tisch bringen
das nicht machen
dass ich nur gemeinde du musst im
prinzip die marke das irgendwie bringe
das eine plätze macht damit der zoll
oder blödsinn macht was ich nicht
gedacht
[Musik]
sage ich nur schön ich zwar noch mit
mühe konnte und ich finde ich ist mir
einfach zu viel und im glarnerland hat
uns einen rückzugsort wo er die berge
genießt und konzentriert arbeiten kann
ein organ wo hat man die inspiration
oder welche mit ideen oder warum hat man
immer noch idee das ist nicht seriös und
faszinierend finde dass wir haben uns
ganz klar damit seine ich muss mehr
zieht und ruhm der beide sachen sind
eigentlich elementare
das projekt wo ist herzensprojekt von
mir gespielt klappt schon seit 20 jahren
ich mir wieder da und ich bin die 15
und wieso weggang die idee in berlin zu
einem abschluss bringen und wird jetzt
das buch draus machen das buch ohne aber
noch gar nicht weiß ob das überhaupt
irgendwie interessiert ich als ich als
ein und zeigt seinen charakter ist das
buch jetzt fertig dass zum beispiel eine
scharfe schätzt gerade an der zahl
weiterer wo man abrufen stiegen wo es
gar nicht höher ist
mit jeder form ist
und das macht sie sehr schwieriger hat
wahnsinnig gut er kann dann muss es sagt
grade noch weiterkommen mit 4 mit der
flüge auf 1 5 meter der bademeister over
projekte betreffend von 5 meter mit
flügel an flügel die absage nicht
grundgefühl und das ist so dass ich ja
[Musik]
in privat habe ich nie alles normal
laufe ich bin mutter aufwachse und all
die tagesmutter kann gott sei dank
ganz toll die lehrpersonen also wie ganz
viel schwieriger sache nicht viel glück
kam charles keiner weise wie die anderen
bin aber aufgrund äußerer art wenn ihr
auf boxer sind mir normal falls sie also
immer kritischer sieht mir hat immer
zeit durchs dach hilfe polizei geschrien
haben ja bekanntlich habe merkt dass das
klappt nicht aber ich handelt bekommt
mit die ganze zeit des pflasters
beeindruckt wenn es jetzt hört man
blüten
[Musik]
und nach ab dem moment wo ich muss noch
eine raus machen oder soll ich gemerkt
dass man an dass ich plötzlich das
problem sondern das land richtig
seitdem führt ca
jetzt landet gelöst was es ist wieder
das empire schon wieder 48-jährige vorne
bin mir jetzt schon zwei jahre wo sie
dann krank sie hat im moment haben wir
erzieher hat oder sich wir inzwischen
gestanden dass sie es nicht oft sogar
hat sie hat ein schlechtes gewissen dass
sie ausgewählt hat und das hat man
gespürt als solche motoren können
einfach herzhaft umarme mich auch nie
drin gesteckt dass sie angst hat dass
sie das viel zu wenig gemacht hatten
papa ich nur da und ich glaube ich sehr
stolz und hat sehr gut mit
brooks war willig exit idealerweise bei
architekten werden
das hat sich dann beruhigt um
drogenhandel brieselang dass das ein
seriöser typisch dass ich glaube so
stumpf
wir hatten noch viel extremer also ich
war so impliziert dass ich habe extrem
bearish us vorbild von mir im notieren
und lichten machen aber fehler gemacht
[Musik]
freestyle improvisiert
das hin und her zwischen haus und honig
ist mir schon am leben stück sie können
frei entscheiden
gutbürgerlich gehörte duftwasser wir
sind vier kriegen sie lustig wenn alle
vier sehr eigene sachen unübersehbar
genickschlag
ich bin der jüngste hat sowieso noch in
freiheit der k&s ich meinen eltern
schnell klar sieht es nicht wert
verliert macht und schriftsetzer aber es
ist ein schnell merkt dass widmet -
inhalt sie und das sicherlich schwierig
b1 schnell merkten sie sind aber
wirklich cool mit dem sich will sie
haben eigentlich am wichtigsten dass du
das machst was die freude macht aber
wenn das manchen macht das wirklich also
großartig wunder dass das rechtlich eine
ganze reihe das hat mir ganz viel neues
in die eltern haben ihren sohn auch dann
unterstützt als er 1990 für sieben
monate ins gefängnis musste weil er den
militärdienst verweigert hatte wegen
guter führung wurde bereits nach
fünfeinhalb monaten die klassen
man merkt da überleben will im militär
muss man eigentlich am besten alles
einfach machen einfach machen ohne zu
denken
militär ist nicht das nicht mensch das
militär ist ein ding das man ist immer
ein ein schäfchen in dieser herde
ich habe für mich das gefühl dass man
nicht ein krieg bekämpfen kann mit
wieder einem krieg oder sowas
wenn es so weit käme dass ich in dem
betrieb funktionieren würde dann dann
wäre ich eine maschine also dann
ich habe sogar das gefühl sie hätten
vielleicht so weit gebracht
von daher das verhältnis zum staat oder
zum recht es ist für mich sehr einfach
sehr fragwürdig
[Musik]
ich mich verliebt was erst mal einen
blick hinter die kulissen werfen
da ist das publikum da ist ja nur auf
der bühne und zuschauer wir machen
häufig der fall dass man es vielleicht
dass ich die person und vor der bühne
kennen
da schreibt an der welt gehen und als
verrucht und das ist nicht so auch das
[Applaus]
gewicht privat bin ich so sehr über
leitet und vorausschauend und häufig als
auch republikaner übersicht und seine
hand auf der bühne bin ich trotz
wichtiger und auch gutgläubiger und dem
direktor frechen gemeiner das ist ganz
anders
die einstellung stimmt alles noch
aussteht
diejenigen unter info kasten und jetzt
benni und erklären warum der straße auf
der bühne staaten nach europa kam und
ich bin ich viel weniger reflektiert
natürlich viel weniger angst
natürlich kenne ich viele logistische
nimmt nicht rücksicht mit dem ganze
routine und das sei nicht nötig habe
viel respekt
ich bin glaube ich ganz anderes kind hat
einfach die porr sache und ich mich fürs
private wünschte das ist mir das mal so
und reflektiert und immer fröhlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe also ich persönlich bin total
paradox oder meint ruf steht aber der
rené mission tube dass man muss
vielleicht zu jeder zeit und überall im
labor nach themen für bühne und mich hat
das projekt das mini mutter so langsam
langsam
du hast vergessen hast du vergessen aber
ich habe mich daraufhin eine alzheimer
hat es wie klaus er weiß nicht dass ich
es wieder los das heißt dass migros und
dann so geht's ja und das mittels und
dann die big stars wie klaas und der
klang macht plötzlich durchs ohr bitte
personal und die freut sich wieder das
wort ich kann den kopf daran hielt so
das spiel definitiv auf der bühne das
heißt linsen egal wo und wann du so
machst dann hat mehr druff druff und
dann durchs eigentlich habe das
schlechter machen nur die heilung dauert
länger als erhofft was nadia sehr
belastet ich verstehe das gerne und das
gotteshaus wieder konnte vor dem findet
floor oder immer noch stürzen finden und
sich im märz weiter kommunikationsmittel
auf der bühne
ich kann so was kürzer waren dass man
besser werden wenn das so bleibt dann
wird im langspieler ich mir längst dem
hof forums patient heißt millionen waren
aber pärchen
johanna bevor fall minister
bandscheibenvorfall immer noch latent
verfolgt woche in rückt langsam vw tour
das war zwar schon 33 aber technisches
ein tag wirklichkeit so fest wie toren
der initiative und 61 sofort das emery
sehr klare bandscheibenvorfall mann
gesagt wir machen schon viel über die
gleichen bewegungen machen aber wir
einfach mal sehr verunsichert
[Musik]
die organisation von beruf und familie
ist für freiberufliche künstlerinnen und
künstler nicht einfach trotzdem nehme
sich urs und gewitter nach möglichkeit
zeit für gegenseitiges feedback
[Musik]
sie stellt sich ganz schick sie dass wir
schon weiter
langhanke befördern der judo ist sicher
sehr viel brachten für organisation der
familie sehr anspruchsvoll ist regler
der batterie bringt schulzeit
unternehmer sicher sind diese woche plan
müsse machen womit projekt und sehr
unregelmäßige arbeitszeiten die
briefschreiber hin und wenn es denn
klappt muss man denn wirklich die stunde
abdecken und daneben der stunde und
jetzt mit der wille ist da sind einmal
das paar stunden
[Musik]
also heute mag ich so oft party und als
ich sie 15 jahre machen also mit über 60
seitige praxistag der sicherheit ihrer
leiden so eine riesige lose also das
umsteigen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sicher für mich eine ganz große kraft
energie und kontakte zu der welt
[Musik]
es gibt ganz viel man die man zwar nur
vor wie frauen sieht aber einig und sich
jetzt schubladisiert aber ich finde es
hat bisher war als der einige
schuhmodelle haus ist einfach genug
humor hat seine witze mit lachen das ist
nur schwierig angehörige der bezirk und
ich komme und haben erfolg das ist nicht
einfach für den partner
ich habe gewusst dass das so ich habe
geführt mittlerweile sich so zeigt sein
soloprogramm kunst aufräumen in
braunwald heute sind auch frau brigitta
und sohn murdoch im publikum mit dabei
sind die macht immer wieder soll sich
unter herrn nicola sein und ich werde
alt uhr vor dem burgtor mit dem titel
kunst aufräumen und jetzt hat mich bei
die nachfrage aus dem buch machen aber
ich bin wirklich schon zweimal ob sie
war schon immer unser schönes bilderbuch
also ich frage wir haben überlegt wie
könnte ich das jetzt machen jetzt
verschiedene bilder oft kopiert und
möchte einfach die die aufzeige
der azubi lieblingsbilder rené magritte
sagt das macht total spaß daran einfach
so sogar ziemlich banal in der
objektkunst pelster vor dem laptop
wahlheimat im ursprungszustand versetzt
ich bin familienvater richtlinie sein
könnten ist aber dass nur einen haben
wir nur noch in richtung sind wenn wir
fehler mal verspielt platz und der armen
in im sandkasten und immer bevor man
high end in der munteren dass er einfach
das reden sagt zu claude ja das komische
letzten sieht worten sogar noch
verspielt man meine stimme tabletop um
frieden aber wenig wichtig bevor man sie
heißt das genau wissen wie viel das sind
sie haben
[Applaus]
durch sichere bis honig von der heyden
sermeter das grundvertrauen ist klaglos
nimmt ist das ist schon drohen oder das
und ein gut oder es muss einmal nicht so
gut
er ist noch krank
so
das urvertrauen das grundvertrauen dass
eine form in ihrer familie sicher sicher
mit überholen und gehofft
[Musik]
am 22
die nächste projekt und muss im moment
freut sich jetzt lustig sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ca
wenn sich das team um sigurdur brand
das ist schwere kost löschen
also ja das probiere ich weiß es nicht
ich das mit innere physio abgesprochen
[Gelächter]
super dass gott der show im sommer
halten
das internet völlig okay aber dass cds
cd schönes und glüht würde garantiert
für fürs zurückziehen auf dem rad jetzt
kannst du musst immer probieren und
stelle als gaucho also sicher
gewöhnungsbedürftig man darf einfach
überhaupt nicht
2002 gastierten ursus und nadeschkin im
zirkus knie fast 18 jahre haben sie
gezögert die manege noch einmal zu
betreten
die bedenken waren große und sind auch
jetzt noch nicht ganz vom tisch
trotzdem wagen sie sich dieses jahr in
die zweite runde des zirkus abenteuers
wahnsinnig finde nicht von mitte 20 bis
[Gelächter]
das ist was ich eben das leben findet
wenn man krank ist und ein auf tour ist
aber vom zirkus ist es
[Musik]
jetzt ist es amtlich premiere in
winterthur und mehrheit im september
vollständiger machen das ist hört die
vorstellungen und die heißt jetzt bei
mir damit ihr sowas war dass wir es ist
schon viel klopft wenn man sich finden
sich sehr haben sich sehr viel wirklich
sehr viel angst und strukturen sondern
jetzt auch parat ich ob ich meinem
auftrag laufen konnte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für ihr neues programm haben ursus und
nadeschkin mit verschiedenen tanzlehrern
gearbeitet
vor der großen premiere ein letzter
probedurchgang mit der tänzerin lola
etwa
[Musik]
ja
ich mache gern fröhlich natürlich
selbstständig aber dass ich am im
internet finde gesellschaft bestellt wie
kinder was ich früher nicht anfreunden
das publikum komplett schöne erwartet
freut und mir ganz gut
auf der bühne
[Musik]
die clubs eine chance
von hand jetzt betritt tut sich
vorstellen wie radfahren heißt wenn du
ins leere programm der die woche im
gleichen theater den explosionen droht
und das war der horror rolle
aber was wir machen ist ja ganz
besonders mehr so viele verschiedene
programme darum weichere sich der
buchhaltung zufälle gedolmetscht machen
jetzt zitat klasse von dem it webseiten
wenn man die schlechte vorstellung vom
analogen muss man das remis
[Musik]
wir sind sehr stolz team zusammen unser
ganzen alles klappt sehr gut und schön
damit ist das meine zahnpasta und
handeln immer los card genau dass er
wirklich ausprobieren und es ist eben
ran und nur für wichtig dass man halt
welle als team wieder kommen sind wir so
einfach so wie geschwister die er sehr
dick verbundenheit wo man geschäfte ganz
wie von magna sie und da steht er ohne
männliche verstärkung
überhaupt nicht einig was eben auch für
die er für die wirtschaft natürlich
spricht dass hummer mit in eine dicke
freundschaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind audio panik davor dass mir wand
mit 10 uhr für groove dass du machst bis
sinnvolles machen und wann blüht mit
einer demo machen ist absolut sinnlos
und dann wenn ich das nicht machen
es gibt so viele moment wo man heute
schon rufe aber wir hatten immer wieder
türke oder nicht so einfach und wir
haben immer also die option haben wir
immer die akteure immer drohung aber wir
finden wenn nicht so interessant
das hatte sich schon zum ausklang
[Musik]
was heißt ein interessiert ist okay wir
haben inzwischen wieder große töne jungs
gang führt
oder anderen ist hat das junge
befürchtet wird dass marina im
altersheim seine auftritte will patrick
laager heike hält zum sich wirklich
trennen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das gefilmt
[Musik]
aber was jetzt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]